I thought they get government subsidies
that's cool I don't know what that means
bro turn the video
off don't say big words to me
[Laughter]
[Music]
dude all right so everybody welcome back
to another awesome episode of the
careful boys featuring Mr Joe Wong Joe
Wong ladies and gentlemen there he is
thanks for having me here again and
again and
again thanks so much it's a lot of fun
this video is coming out first actually
oh really oh no now I look like a crazy
person that's okay I just you know it's
a Chris Christopher
Nolan the end starts yeah exactly
momento okay so um I wanted to pose this
question everybody's open to answering
this of course uh in their own native
country tongue oh oh tongue yes but
nobody's going to understand when I
speak
Joe's Joe will what did you say I
already did misunderstood that
anyway um yeah Joe will that's very
good what okay especially because you
know you said you were living in China
and then you recently came to America
all right what do you
like more about China versus America or
what do you like more about America
versus China everybody's more than
welcome to answer in their own native
country pretty cool can't we just talk
about China yeah it's not America's
native to Me Foo but what I do okay
thank you yeah do but what I what I do
like about Japan is I was asking him
first to worry about any
dangers that's a pretty good one [__]
cuz in all over all over the world I
feel like there's the there's the danger
sense threat like Public Safety right no
yeah you're right I'm like there's a
there's a homeless man there he looks
like he's about to bite me and then
they're like those bunch of guys oh
they're just playing they're just
playing sports they're not they're not
they're not going to try to rob me
whatever right or like and then you go
to even Europe even Europe they're like
oh that guy's playing the [__] ball
game they're going to try to Jack me you
know it's just the cup thing yeah yeah
yeah it's I feel like oh there's a drunk
guy there looking for fight whatever
yeah there's always a threat but then
when when you're in Japan it's just
Sailor Moon everywhere that's pretty
cool does that also apply to every city
in Japan no I mean there is the the the
crazy [__] but that's like one area in
Tokyo that's not the whole country it's
actually the whole country is safe and
then you got like a pocket of [__] up
places that's really small it's like two
streets it is so impressively safe yeah
it is you definitely don't feel too much
danger there I I do envy that about
Japan now what's something you like
about America that Japan can't do guns
baby that's the reason why it's not safe
by the
way the complete
opposite the funny thing you know he's
telling the truth that's absolutely the
truth I love the contrast I love it
that's so good that's why he lives in
eight different places dude two
different
Lifestyles one is I'm in the forest with
a gun on my side and and then we can go
into anywhere and just do targets and
whatever and then that it's there's a
lot of space then the others is just you
know completely different culture
different world I don't know if they
have bears but when I'm camping you know
I don't think like a bear is going to
bite me I don't know I think they do
have Bears I've just never been camping
you went all the way to Japan to Camp no
I'm imagining that I was camping there
yeah I'm like there's a lot in Downtown
LA you know you have to go to Japan to
go camping yeah you we got tents
everywhere exactly we got too many
really but do you do you regularly carry
a gun with you or yeah oh wow yeah I
think it's wonderful I think it's it's
fun
gundul this guy go through goes through
ammo so quickly yeah he just gives it
out dude what what about you for you is
there like anything you like about China
more than America or America yeah
well for China I was say the the tween
oh yeah yeah EXA right the twen syst I
got you said the train yeah I bet that's
dope I mean the the high speeed TNS
they're really high speed you know it's
like 300 km per hour wow that's they are
sick not faster than
Japan but I'm I'm I never took a tween
in Japan but uh you know this you know
I'm talking about China just like it was
so on time the efficiency yeah just
I remember one couple from Canada were
on the same train they were like they
just came from
Italy they took the train in Italy they
were like they even got the uh stops uh
got the station Nam wrong you know the
the radio was saying that the next
station is this but it's actually not
they just completely messed up but then
they forgot their own station name the
Italians were Italians yeah even from
the speakers it was long station you
know but then like China just everything
is so well run especially the rail
system and that's part of the reason why
the comedy scene boom so much it's also
comedians can make a good living just
travel to different cities to do comedy
so oh they don't need to drive oh no
they don't have to drive just like half
hour train you know one hour train
you're in another city doing three shows
here and then Zoom you're back or you
know just very convenient that's true
that's pretty cool EXA yeah yeah that
eliminates a whole you the train here oh
yeah I did it was a disgrace man just
like I rode the train from uh Boston to
New York high speed 24 hours I'm like
are you kidding me this you know like
this twin station also you know just oh
my God so gross oh yeah this just so so
messy that was a highpe speed American
train it's 4 hours that's a Salah from
yeah Boston New York yeah have you taken
a train in La yet no I haven't don't
ever do it they're so nice oh okay never
ever do it I took the metro to Chinatown
from Pasadena I think no no no from here
from the there's like a station right
here also 4
hours hours that's about like 5
miles yeah so what do you like about
America more oh uh America has one thing
that China doesn't uh which is uh
Chinatown
[Laughter]
[__] he got me there yeah he's like holy
[__] I he absolutely right the only yeah
I recently saw this uh short video of
This American dude in in tungu I was
hilarious he was like look I'm in
Chinatown in tungu I'm like every every
city in China is a Chinatown what are
you talking about thought it was
Chinatown yeah yeah that's so funny I
know
but sometimes the American tourists will
make the most insane comments where
outside of America yeah most recently I
saw this group of kids in Paris uh in
front of the Eiffel Tower and one said
just oh I still prefer the epot
center who would say such a thing Epcot
Center yeah yeah but then they got into
an argument you know oh Avoca Center is
better no no the real real friend is
better that's the dumbest story and then
someone comes in and goes Las Vegas is
better yeah exactly yeah have you been
to that Eiffel Tower that's in China oh
there there I don't know which one there
are quite a few there's are quite a few
quite a few yeah makes sense China is
nuts which one's the best
one so so basically there isn't anything
in America that's uh that you like
better oh um which is okay yeah
yeah
just very different con like what what
he was saying you know just different
style I guess it's like a opposite is
cool yeah how different it is I mean you
know I love the you know like New York
comedy scene I think that's great you
know just I don't know I've never been
to London or anything but I still feel
that the comedy scene in New York is
probably the best yeah so the New York
New Yorkers culture you can't find
anywhere else in the world probably not
yeah yeah I I heard this funny
stereotype or about New Yorkers they say
mean things but they're actually very
nice and West coasters they act very
nice but they're actually very mean oh
yeah yeah that's true
yeah if you go to New York
people are very uh T you know they're
abrupt you know but then they actually
help you you know that's that's the
difference I guess you know
but damn we suck over here huh we got
nothing yeah we're pretty [__] what
about uh we probably got better
hamburgers than than China China
probably I I wouldn't say that seriously
oh yeah hamburgers are really good we're
getting beat out in hamburgers yeah if
you go to cuz I what I had there's uh
some restaurants in in um Shaman when I
performed there this Chef came from New
York oh and their burgers such oh my God
it was so good you know just just
today's video is brought to you by Lumi
I've been doing a lot of research about
deodorant and I said dang how come
there's so much aluminum and all of
these different brands that I've been
wearing I've been sucking that up in my
skin and what I decided to do is just
altogether stop until Lumi came to my
rescue because did you know this is
paraben free aluminum free they got all
kinds of whack ass Metals that'll soak
you into your skin and turn you into uh
tox Iron Man and what's cool it was
designed by an actual doctor a
OBGYN and she designed a deodorant for
the hooa and then she realized wait if
it's sensed enough and pH balanc enough
for the HOA why don't I make deodorant
for your whole body and what's cool is
instead of covering up the odor she
treats it at the source so that it
doesn't even smell to begin with yeah
this is one of my favorite smells
Tangerine Girl if you put this from head
to toe talking to my wife I will lick it
all over and there's other forms too
like deodorant wipes you got whole body
deodorant cream up to 72 hours so if
you're one of those stinky ass
[__] you could wear this and
that's me and don't worry that you're
going to smell for 3 Days yep and you
can put it in every crevice of your body
from the armpit to the neck pit belly
button ass pit yep everywhere yep and
the Lumi starter pack right here is
perfect for new customers very perfect
comes with the solid Stick deodorant and
the cream tube deodorant and two free
products of your choice like the mini
body wash or the deodorant wipes and
they got free shipping that's the best
part as a special offer for listeners
new customers get $5 off a Lumi starter
pack with the code OTR at lumid
deodorant.com that equates to over 40%
off your Lumi starter pack when you
visit lumid deodorant.com and use the
code OTR I'm still going to argue with
you on this this one you might have
found one really good of course yeah I
went to McDonald's in Beijing and it
tastes the same I mean McDonald's that's
it should right that's because
McDonald's is his own country yeah kind
of they're pretty good it's a it's an
embassy
technically I think I think one of the
best burgers I had was in Philippines
really but one thing I was impressed was
uh this was back in 2020 during the
pandemic I went to a McDonald's in
Beijing
and their employees are driving like
subar to work and stuff you know it's
like they get paid good yeah they're
quite well paid you know that's pretty
impressive you know that's pretty that
is good to know I think my favorite
thing about here so I'm from Taiwan um
or like my mother country I guess what I
like about America is like the
um the no
preset like pipeline to Upward Mobility
like taiwan's like very structured you
have to do really good in elementary
school to get into really good middle
school to get into a really good high
school to get into a good college and
then that kind of like that whole
pipeline is almost preset to get to
where you want to be in life in America
you can be like 50 Cent and shoot people
go to jail and then come out and then
within 5 years you're like a millionaire
my mom was like America is like the land
of many mistakes yeah like many chances
yeah like if you have the will work
ethic there's literally nothing Stopping
You versus preset like it's almost like
you can draw your like if you have two
points you can draw your own like
shortest distance between two points
it's true versus in Taiwan it's like
it's preset how you need to arrive
places and there's no innovation of how
you arrive there um so that was my
favorite thing about here I think my
favorite thing about Taiwan versus
here is
um I think more more of a nostalgic
thing where it feels really cozy like
when I used to go visit my grandparents
and it's like uh it's crazy cuz it'll be
like a skysc scraper and then there's
like a guy like [__] on the
floor and it's like night market and the
city is like this together everything is
like there's like a stinky tofu cart and
then the the tallest building in the
world at that time and then another
guy that's like picking his toenails and
then it's just like it's just like crazy
all in one and then so it feel but then
it doesn't feel like it clashes you know
it's just all part of the culture the
culture is you can work a crazy white
collar job and then get street food and
it's all like intermingled into one like
it's cool to like you know versus like
here like let's say if you worked at the
US Bank building and you're some crazy
white call a worker in Downtown LA more
than likely you're not going to go to a
Atlantic taco truck for lunch you're
probably going to go eat at Mastro
Steakhouse or you know or if you do it's
almost like they're warning their
buddies like dude we're going to go get
some [__] tacos bro it's [__]
dangerous like you know it's like there
like they're almost about to enter a
different world like they don't have
that there it's just it's the same world
it's the same thing you can roll up in a
Mercedes and then eat a [__] chicken
skewer and it's like normal
yeah it doesn't look weird right it's
like all part of the same I like the
night market there me too my favorite
thing about Philippines is that
everybody no matter if they're like rich
or poor most of them are going to be
poor but everybody's primed to laugh oh
yeah everybody has time JY huh like
there's it's very rare that you'll find
someone like snoody like uh they just
want to have fun so like if you could
talk to someone and and you can make
random people laugh like instantly cuz
everybody just just has the same I guess
like openness to humor that's dope
that's tight which is like very
noticeable when you're out there cuz
like you could find a lot of people that
don't seem like there's enough to be
happy about but they are smiling and
they're having a good time and you know
never with that met an uptight Filipino
that's true it's hard that's
snobby I've never I've never seen it
that's why they're so likable dude even
if you go to like cuz like we went to
like they're Jolly bees dude yeah you go
to like bars like dive bars the people
that are in there even though there's a
distinct economic difference between
them and the people at like an exclusive
Club the vibe is still very similar oh
wow like even though you know they're
way richer like out here the vibe is
like completely different you go to like
a upscale club and a dive bar right but
you can't talk to some people in some
places some venues they just won't speak
to you out there it's like they're down
to laugh if you're if you're like down
to laugh then so are they it's cool yeah
I I do like like that about it what
about America over Philippines uh it's
it's very similar to what you said I I
really like that everybody has a shot
even if it's not the same shot and it's
not the fairest shot for everybody
everyone has a shot if they can find the
angle yeah that's really cool the
angle's findable exactly like it exists
you know like we like like herk he went
to jail for bank rob he came out a
millionaire like what the heck is that
you know what I me that's almost unheard
of in Asia you're tainted after you go
you have any criminal record what what
could be having somebody running for
president from jail you know exactly
yeah yeah yeah that's my favorite thing
about America is it's the land of
surprises and it's like the randomst
craziest coolest thing can happen to you
but also at the same time you could just
get robbed and die like Tom Cruz is
notoriously dyslexic and he's the
biggest like actor right in Asia it's
like if you can't even read how are you
going to get through acting a Academy or
theater like you would just get washed
out like there would be no unicorn
stories whereas in America it's filled
with unicorn stor we got a different set
of PRX like it doesn't really apply in
the same way and you can have wildly
untalented people become the biggest
stars everyone has a shot right you know
you know what makes me go like America
oh it's this side America right America
you know what makes me do that is when I
go to other countries even if it's
Western they don't Pro promote
entrepreneurialism and like creativity
Innovation to the point where we do like
we're very open and honest about success
it's like very like we're like we're
proud of it like we share it we don't
put each other down on it's like oh [__]
you're opening up a gym that's [__]
tight tell me about it right like yeah
there is some haters or whatever but
like the way that
it's glorified versus other countries
are more like oh let's keep it lowkey or
like they even demonize people that are
self starters or trying to build a sh
yeah like they're more like what makes
you so special like I feel like a lot of
Asian countries and European countries
are like that where it's like crabs in
the bucket and it's like oh you're
standing out too much and so people
don't aspire to be Innovative and
entrepreneurial more so like maybe
Innovative in like the science field or
something like research or whatever
right but I almost feel like America
there's no um negative weight to
Desiring wanting to build a business or
do something entrepreneurial it's almost
like oh good for you the the mentality
is way different yeah cuz I feel like
Japan and maybe even the UK they're more
like um keep your head down do average
[__] why why why do you think you're so
special you could go beyond what other
people are doing
yeah what's the Vietnam thing for you um
I'll give a I got like a super ficial
one I got a little bit deeper one but
like for example in Vietnam I just enjoy
the fact that everybody could like ride
like scooters and motorcycles and bike
different places and that's just like
the type of life where you want to get
somewhere just convenience yeah like
five people can get on a motorcycle
that's not breaking the law you know
what I mean you just got to get to where
you got to get that's pretty cool yeah
real whereas here you guys get LA
traffic whereas in America for example I
honestly love the fact that we have sick
movies and music like just the media and
the art just the way that we do like
media and art I just [__] love it and
the way it influences the rest of the
world you know what I mean um but on a
deeper level in that weird contrasting
dichotomy there's times where I love the
fact that for America we have so much
like so many different diverse peoples
and everybody has so much like freedom
but then it also becomes like a point of
like complexity and difficulty in so
many ways where sometimes you look at
like another Nation that's like one
people with like maybe even a communist
government and they all have to abide by
the rules and they all have to do a
certain things or they can't do certain
things but then that also becomes a
point of like peace and and the way that
people work like cohesiveness yeah and
things kind of make sense so it's like
depending on what you're into or what is
is convenient at that time things work
out for you but then
the same concept is like something that
may be difficult for you in a different
way you know what I mean we're we're
minorities in America sometimes so there
we have so much to learn from other
cultures and we have this appreciation
for different elements of the world even
food but at the same time we'll face
like racial you know discrimination and
a reign of [__] like that whereas you go
to your your mother country and you're
just like all one people and every they
you they don't have those problems but
then maybe you don't have the same
freedom of opportunity to like excel in
in certain ways or what not Japanese
people are so racist they'll kick my ass
out and say I'm not Japanese enough they
they tried to bring Brazilians back
Brazilian Japanese full blood and
they're like this ain't working out go
back to Brazil oh damn hundreds of
thousands of them [__] Japanese
people are racist
bro so racist but I love going there cuz
it's so fun it's so awesome maybe maybe
the key to uh safety and peace is
racism be more racist if I don't know
you get out of here what's up
Singaporean what do you say Singapore
look that's not kind of not fair though
Singapore is kind of a [__] Singapore
is tough Nick is like what I love about
Singapore is the caning and um the lack
of gum on the streets and I like the
catch and release program of
La man like I've only been to Singapore
as an adult like like one time right and
it it was pretty quick but also say this
the convenience of the train station
kind of like Joe I was like this is
tight to be able to get but it's also
such a small country Public Services out
there is pretty fun but like my personal
preference is just like the food scene I
just and it's not like we can't get a
crazy food scene out here but to me the
food scene over there like all the
Hawkers the outdoor stuff like to me I
don't
know I think it's more of just the
culture side cuz it's like you can still
get whatever you want like cuz Singapore
is modern like it does kind of feel like
California a lot of ways but it also
doesn't but I think the the the food
culture and just the The Nostalgia of
how it reminds me of like my mom and my
family that I don't get to see so it'll
probably be more of those reasons uh and
then America it's kind of like all what
you guys think it's like I don't want to
be cliche but the freedom of being able
to kind of do whatever you want in the
the lane being in a whatever Lane that
you want and creating your own lane is
unlike anything else and I just feel
like there is something special about it
and anytime I go to any country I always
come back saying like man we got it so
good in the states so good like there is
just nothing like it and when I hear
people complain about it you just go
like shut the [__] up do you start
travel more do you do you start reciting
the Pledge of Allegiance in front of
them to silence them I should you should
we should start doing I should just put
my hand on my heart and [__] when
they start talking [__] about America be
like
bro traveling more does make you really
it it makes you appreciate what we got
dude The Simple Pleasures of driving on
a paved Road you I mean like we we got a
[__] pretty great system you know
have you ever been to a country though
where you're just like [__] I never
thought I'd find a place better than
America not yet not yet but there's
aspects though right but you you're also
in this mindset of like of course this
feels great because you're on vacation
like if you had really had to live here
yeah when you picture yourself living
there it's different like you're I think
the lens changes completely of course
yeah but that's true try to be try to be
a a highend chicken stall in in in what
is it Singapore yeah dude you try to be
that guy you're like you're like this is
good cuz you're the customer exactly and
I paid $5 for it right you know like
there's nothing like what we get out
here imagine being the business owner of
that highly competitive yeah making
sense every day sense that's what that's
what I thought he said I thought they
get subsidized now huh I thought they
get government subsidies that's cool I
don't know what that means bro turn the
video
off don't say big words to me
[Laughter]
dude